[Musique]
je n'oserais
jackson vous avez travaillé pendant
quatre ans sur le documentaire quête bac
en fait c'est l'histoire de la
production de l'album plus la libye et
vous avez eu accès à 57 heures de bandes
vidéo c'est un rêve pour les fans mais
pour vous aussi j'imagine que c'était un
grand rêve
vous avez aussi joué au journaliste
peter jackson parce que on le sait la
production de l'ennemi ont longtemps eu
mauvaise presse vous avez voulu montrer
une autre image
/
[Musique]
notre mémoire peut lui jouer de mauvais
tours alors comment paul mccartney et
ringo starr ont réagi après avoir vu
votre film
[Musique]
votre documentaire est d'une durée de 6
heures mais vous avez travaillé avec 57
heures de film est ce qu'un jour on
pourrait avoir droit à un documentaire
de votre part je sais pas 20 heures
vous avez accompli de grands rêves en
réalisant le seigneur des anneaux
maintenant get back bebeto ce à quoi
rêvez-vous maintenant jackson
peter jackson ça a été un plaisir de
vous parler merci
[Musique]